at least grant me that Star Wars had a
more believable political system
factions internal struggle how the whole
thing collapsed on itself
when was Roddenberry's Galactic
Federation anything other than perfect
via discovered country one botched
assassination attempt and a single
notable inside man barely counts they're
keeping it pretty civil give it a minute
Enterprise Phantom Menace Spock's brain
Jar Jar Binks final frontier uncle Owen
Wesley Crusher midi-chlorian okay I'm
taking the prequels off the table
without them you've got nothing
sure and I'm sure if you take genocide
off the table Hitler was it all-around
good guy to just another struggling
vegetarian painter I'm serious original
trilogy only now what have you got
whiny leak he had to start out that way
in order to complete the journey from
boy to man and hero pointless special
edition adults original cut only okay
stormtroopers are me what about it what
pray tell is the point of bright white
armor protection oh when they got here
with blaster fire they drop like rocks
so it clearly offers no projection check
and it's bright reflective white they
couldn't have been an easier target with
bull's-eyes on their helmets they must
have lost their mind when they got to
invade ha because any place besides a
snow planet and it's like they've been
highlighted I still call that a nitpick
at best fine then he walks you're going
to walk he walks and defend a series
that had tribbles firstly there's
nothing wrong with tribbles secondly
those at once
deal so we're the ewoks excuse me to
spin-off movies and a cartoon show
those aren't Canon still counts Matt
back me up on this
don't you dare drag me into this again
you both know where I stand
yeah with an asexual alien nerd whose
arch enemy is a rolling trash can you
damn right well I would have been
partial to Babylon 5